[Music]
in recent years the Mandeville community
has changed significantly with large
growth and small block rural and
residential areas in light of this we're
reviewing speed limits in the area to
make sure the community is safe and
speed limits are consistent
inappropriate these roads are limited to
50 km/h these roads the limited to 70
km/h and these two stretches of Road are
limited to 80 km/h all remaining roads
currently have an open road speed limit
of 100 km/h there are three areas of
interest that we are focusing on and
let's review should the section of tram
Road have a lower speed limit should
these lengths of wards road Dawson's
road and bread leeds road have lower
speed limits to be consistent with
McHugh's road in Mandeville road and
should these cul-de-sacs and access
roads have lower speed limits to be
consistent with the mill field
subdivision we are holding drop-in
sessions on these dates or you can find
out more and give us feedback at
waimakariri govt TMZ ford / Mandeville
you
[Music]